has been just devastating I'm I'm still
a little number buddy George Floyd's the
younger brother Terrence speaks out if
you angry it's okay to be angry but
channel your anger to do something
positive will make it change another way
because we've been we've been down this
road already we've been down this road
already he would want he would want us
to seek justice the way we are the way
we're trying to do but channel it
another way Terrence was a guest on
Mondays Good Morning America where he
opened up to Robin Roberts about the
death of his older brother and the kind
of person he was he was about peace
unity he fully when you when you spoke
to him he always wanted to motivate you
no matter what she was going through you
know he always sort of delight at the
brightest side of things
Terrence plans to visit the site where
his brother died I just want to feel my
brother's spirit I just want to I don't
know for lack of better terms just
connect with him again as et previously
reported
George Floyd died on May 25th at just 46
years old after he was arrested for
suspicion of forgery outside of a deli
the video of the arrest shows him on the
ground repeatedly telling the white
police officer identified as derrick
Chauvin who was kneeling on his neck
that he couldn't breathe Floyd was later
pronounced dead
joven now an ex-police officer has since
been arrested in relation to George's
death the current protests come after
decades upon decades of similar
instances that have resulted in what
feels like deja vu for Americans
George's brother is hoping and
encouraging positive change as some
protests have become violent I do feel
like it's over sad when what's going on
because like I said he was about peace
he's about unity well the things that's
transpiring now
yeah they may call it unity but it to
its destructive unity it's not it's not
what he was about today so many are hurt
angry and broken because of the feeling
that black lives are devalued in the US
the majority of the protests have been
peaceful and we're seeing people coming
together we want to be with y'all for
real so I took the helmet off delayed
the batons down I want to make this a
parade hugs people so you tell us what
you eat II spoke with Sheriff a chris
Swanson of Flint Michigan who now
famously took off his riot gear to join
the people marching so you put down your
stuff and you're walking with everyone
and what is the reaction among people
around you well I could tell you that
guy it was it was electric you had
people that had no face and in one
moment they saw that the police were
with them and it took and again I'm not
a hero I'm not a I'm not somebody that
duh that wants to get any attention
individually but you know it takes
police leadership it takes experience
and training but more importantly takes
the heart of a human being to show love
and dignity and respect for another
human being and all the folks won and it
was someone to hear them not to just
whisper words and it takes cops to come
from behind their desks from outside
their conference rooms from outside
their podiums from the top down in to go
into the community and I can tell you
that this to those folks they're a
street-smart and when you are in the
community and you try to say something
and it doesn't come from here folks pick
it up quick
and they knew that the heart was right
because I grew up in jail I grew up as a
police officer 27 years tomorrow's my
anniversary so I understand people I've
been on the mission field
I understand
and all I wanted these folks to just
know that I'm here for you these cops
are here for you and 800,000 cops around
the United States are here for you